- [Instructor] We're told
that David hosts a podcast
and he is curious how much
his listeners like his show.
He decides to start with an online poll.
He asks his listeners to visit his website
and participate in the poll.
The poll shows that 89% of
about 200 respondents "love"
his show.
What is the most concerning
source of bias in this scenario?
And well, like always,
pause this video and see
if you can figure it out on your own
and then we'll work through it together.
Let's think about what's going on.
He has this population
of listeners, right?
I'll assume that the number
of listeners is more than 200.
And he says, "Hey I want to find a sample,
"and I can't ask all of my listeners."
Who knows, maybe he has 10,000 listeners,
they don't tell us that, but let's say
there's 10,000 listeners here.
And he says, "Well I
want to get an indication
"of what percentage like my show.
"So I need a sample."
But instead of taking
a truly random sample,
he asks them to volunteer.
He asks his listeners
to visit his website.
So that's classic volunteer
response sampling.
This is not random because who decides
to go to his website and
listen to what he just said,
and maybe even has access to a computer.
That's not random.
In fact, the people
more likely to do that,
so these are the people out of the 10,000,
these are the 200 responders
here who decided to do it.
These are more likely to be
the people who already like
David or like to listen to
what he tells them to do.
The people, the listeners
who are not into David
or don't want to do what
he tells them to do,
they're unlikely to say, "Oh,
I'm not really into David
"and I don't like him
telling me what to do,
"but hey, I'm gonna go
to his website anyway,
"I'm gonna fill out that poll."
That's less likely.
Or you might get extremes,
people who really don't like him,
might say, "I'm gonna
definitely go there."
But in this case, I would
say that it's more likely
your fans are gonna do
what you ask them to do
and go to your website and
spend time on your website.
And because of that, that 89%
is probably an overestimate.
89% is probably an overestimate
of the number of listeners
who really love his show.
Cause you're more likely to
get the ones who love him
to show up and fill
out that actual survey.
Now these other forms of bias.
Response bias, this is when
you're asking something
that people don't necessarily
want to answer truthfully,
or the way that it's phrased,
it might make someone
respond, you see, in a biased way.
Classic examples of this are like,
"Have you lied to your
parents in the past week?"
Or "have you ever cheated on your spouse."
Something, "do you smoke?"
Any of these things that
people might not want
to answer completely truthfully
or they might be hiding
from the world, they might
not just want to answer
that truthfully on a survey.
And so you're going to have response bias.
But that's not the case right over here.
And undercoverage is when
the way that you're sampling,
you're definitely missing out
on an important constituency.
Voluntary response
we're likely missing out
on some important
constituencies, on some people
who might not be into
going to your website,
but undercoverage is where
it's a little bit more clear
that that is happening.
Let's do another case,
let's do another case,
maybe an alternate reality
where David's trying
to figure this out again,
he's still hosting a podcast,
he's still curious how much
his listeners like his show,
but he tries to take a different sample.
He decides in this case, to
poll the next 100 listeners
who send him fan emails.
They don't all respond, but 94 out
of the 97 listeners polled
said they "loved his show."
What is the most concerning
source of bias in this scenario?
Well this is a classic,
"Hey I have a group,
"I have a sample sitting in front of me,
"it's in my inbox in my email,
let me just go to them."
Isn't that convenient?
So this is classic convenience sample.
And this isn't just like,
hey, these are the first 100
people to walk through the door
and there's, a lot of times you can argue
why that might be not so random,
but these're the next 100
listeners who sent him fan emails.
(laughing)
So this is convenience
sampling and the sample
that you happen to use out of convenience
is one that's going to be
very skewed to liking you.
So once again, this is overestimating,
overestimating the percent,
the percent that love his show.
Now nonresponse is when you
ask a certain number of people
to fill out a survey or
to answer a questionnaire,
and for some reason, some
percent do not fill it out.
And you're like, "Wow,
who are those people?
"Maybe they would have
said something important
"and maybe their viewpoint
"is not properly represented
in the overall number
"that actually did fill it out."
And there is some
nonresponse going on here.
He asks 100 people who
sent fan emails to fill out
the survey to say whether
they love it or not,
97 fill it out.
So there are three people who
did not fill out the survey.
So there is some nonresponse going on
that would be a source of bias,
but it's not the most concerning.
Right over here they're
asking us, fill out
the most concerning source of bias,
and the convenience sampling is definitely
the biggest deal here.
There were three people
who didn't respond,
but that's not as big of a deal.
Voluntary response sampling.
Well, he didn't ask people,
like in the last example,
"Hey, if you can go here and fill it out?"
I guess, I take that back,
there is a little bit
of voluntary response here,
where he goes to these 100 people
and he asks them to respond.
And so you have the 97
people who chose to respond.
But once again, that
could be a source of bias,
but most of the 97 of
the 100 are responding,
and once again, the most concerning thing
is the convenience sampling,
which will once again,
based on this sample that
he's happening to use
out of convenience, is going to be a very,
a significant overestimate in terms of
representing the entire
population of his listeners.